arrestation en belgique du compagnon
d'évasion de jacques mesrine françois
bès avait d'ailleurs participé à de
nombreux coups en compagnie de mesrine
après leur évasion de la santé depuis
plusieurs mois il semble que baisse
avait pris certaines distances par
rapport à l'ennemi public numéro un
c'est à issel dans la banlieue de
bruxelles que les policiers belges ont
arrêté en compagnie de trois de ses
complices
alerté par les hommes de la brigade de
répression du banditisme français les
policiers belges lui entendu une
souricière françois besse a donc été
repris toutefois rien ne laisse supposer
que cette arrestation met les enquêteurs
sur la trace de mesrine mesrine qui
reste la priorité des priorités pour les
policiers français
[Musique]